hello everyone and welcome to what
appears to be the greatest and probably
the most precise game played in the in
the candidates so far we have a circuit
correction with the white pieces against
Fabiano car won at the tournament leader
going into this game this is around 12
of the candidates Caruana has seven
points and Sergei kirkin has six points
so he's he's a point behind and if he
wins this game he will catch up the
Fabiano and he will he will share the
lead in the tournament basically so
before we before we start this game I
only have one photo of this round it's a
photo of Sergey Kerrigan here here we
can enjoy it in full-screen it's it's a
bit the photo is a bit weird but kurakin
always looks a bit weird on photos but
you know as they say it's better to be
weird on photos than over the board now
for some reason Nikki didn't get her
photo of Fabi for some reason maybe he
was late for the game I have no idea but
I did update the profile photos of the
players here on the left side of the
board so there's a there's a nice photo
of a beader so let's see the game
kurakin goes for efore as he is the
probably the most precise efore player
in this field and we have a 5 by going
if for he challenges Fabiano to his
petro defense as the Fabiano played the
better of defense against anyone who
challenged him with efore and he hasn't
lost a single game yet so definitely a
reasonable thing to do
Knight to f3 Knight to f6 Knight
captures only five d6
Knight to f3 this is the classical
variation Knight captures on e4 and not
Knight to c3 my favorite line against
the Petrov Knight captures on c3 d
captures on c3 and now Knight to c6
Bishop to e3
we have Bishop to e7 Queen to d2
preparing queenside castle Bishop to e6
and here we do have queenside castle and
corona plays Queen to d7 here Bishop
captures on a2 does the condemned is
Bishop 2 to be captured but it's also a
playable line but is since since score
can allows this after after you capture
here of course we will play
three you want to trap the bishop would
king - he came to beat - but then a five
and after King to be - a four and the
black will get a reasonable attack for
for this Bishop King captures now Punk
after zombie three King has the capture
on b3 and now rook to a5 preparing Queen
to eight you have to go back Queen to
eight and now Rock the b1 making room
for the for the King to escape and
although black it does appear like black
achieved something but he doesn't fully
have compensation so Sergei was
obviously very prepared for this so
after this queenside castle Queen to d7
and now a3 not allowing the bond to be
captured anymore h6 Knights the d4
Knight captures Bishop captures and here
rook to g8 he doesn't want to allow this
rook to stay on h8 since the bishop is
indeed for suburb to g8 maybe preparing
to put g5 f5 in the future obviously
announcing that he will indeed Castle
queenside Bishop to e2 we have c5 now
but should be back to e3 and now d5 f
for preventing black from executing g5
immediately preparing Bishop to f3
Caruana castles Queen side here and here
we have Bishop to f3 and here if Bobby
want f5 and this does seem to lock the
position down and you know everything
stays the same everything is fine on the
board the game continues but I believe
here Bobby really got got scared of
actually winning the candidates and he
played Bishop to g4 with the idea of
exchanging pieces but here I believe
Cara can smell the blood as he isn't
interested in trading pieces he
immediately played Bishop captures on d5
he decided to sacrifice the exchange
here the rook on d1 so you don't have to
capture it now Bishop captures rook
captures and now getting the Queen out
of the D file Queen to c7 and now c4 so
Cara King grabbed a pawn he's down the
exchange but that's that's a monster
bishop on d5 black no longer has a light
square bishop he still has the bishop
repair and
it's it's hard to say if those rooks
will be able to get any action in this
game so rook g28 we have Queen to F to
now be six more protection to the c5
pawn g4 we have better up to f6 and now
King to be one rook to d7
rook to d3 g v now and here King to a to
rocky to e7 and here Queen to f3 King to
d8 and this is a actually one of the
critical moments in the game King today
it is not the most precise way to go
here Kara can play Bishop to d2 and
better to d2 is an excellent move here
he also had the opportunity which I'm
sure he decided wasn't worth going into
the play F captures in g5 because after
Bishop captures Bishop captures H
captures you have Bishop to c6
now of course threatening to win back
win back your exchange and after rook
captures on d3 Queen captures on d3 this
is with check you have to move the King
King to see it only move and now you
have Queen to f5 check of course you
have to move the King King to be eight
and now Queen captures on g5 and here of
course if black captures Queen have like
after the bishop you capture the rook on
e7 but here you would have these two
very strong points the H pawn is a
passed pawn and it would be very hard
for black to counter this Queen to e5
offering a trade of Queens but now Queen
g8 check King moves Queen to a8 and
after King moves now to d5 guarding all
the squares around the black King and
it's it's hard to say if black could
hold this but instead of this forcing
variation Kara can went for an on
forcing variation but that will be just
just as forcing in the end here if he
played a bishop to d2 and it seems like
a weird move to play but not really
corrections plan is Queen to f1 making
room for the rook then rook to h3 and
then trying to infiltrate
Bobby from behind so we have King King
to see it and now Queen to f1 and it's
interesting
Queen to
three would the same idea of him
infiltrating would the Queen does not
work because after a queen to h3g
characters on f4 and Queen captures on
h6 you have Bishop to e5 and now this
Queen to f8 check doesn't work you can
simply block this Queen to d8 and now
Bishop to b7 with the idea of winning
back the exchange is actually favorable
for black so King can simply capture as
Queen captures rook captures and have to
route chapter 78 you do have you want a
pawn here and it seems like you're
better off here but the the past f1 is
extremely dangerous as you can't attack
it from behind it because the f1 is
doubled so after something like King to
c6 came to b3 now f3 rook to d3 stopping
the pawn but now rook to d7 and if white
trades rook rooks here then the F pawn
will be will be too strong so here white
would have to capture and black would
win a piece here rope characters rookie
actress on h1 and it's hard to say maybe
maybe white could actually hold this but
but probably not so kurakin calculates
precisely that Queen to h3 doesn't work
he plays Queen to f1 makes room for rook
to h3 so rook these six and now not
immediately rope to h3 firstly plays F
captures and g5 Bishop captures and g5
and now Queen to f5 check now we have
rook d2 d7 now Bishop CalPERS on g5 8h
capture son g5 and Queen captures and g5
here
Fabiano plays Queen to e5 he offers a
trade of Queens it'd be excellent if
there was time to actually capture the
h2 point but if Queen captures on h2
then you get Queen to g8 check King c7
and after Queen to eight black is simply
doomed there's really nothing for you to
play a v g5 is coming g5 is a very much
needed move that it's it's easy to find
if you if we try to see what black is
trying to do black could definitely try
to defend it with f6i preventing this
point from being pushed forward so g5
would be a must play move after Queen to
e5 now better to b7 rook to e8 but now
rook captures King captures and Bishop
to c6 check King moves and Queen
captures on the 8th and it's all over
Queen captures Bishop captures here up
apiece you're winning this game
so after this Queen to g5 move there's
no time for Fabi to actually capture the
h2 pawn he played Queen to e5 and now
comes Queen to h6 it's interesting
now King the Queen to g8 with the same
idea doesn't work of course Queen Queen
is on in five you can simply block this
with the rook so after this Queen to e5
now comes Queen to h6 King to d8 and
another questionable move because this
gives white a perfect opportunity to
play this g5 move which Fabio obviously
missed if there wasn't for this g5 move
a black could have this excellent
resource of playing f6 then there's no
longer g5 and it's not that easy to push
the H pawn now that this pawn is in g5
you can no longer push the F pawn
because then g6 is coming so
unfortunately for example if Cara can
decided to push h4 here thinking that
it's all the same then f6 and it's not
that easy to push those pawns anymore
but okay King to the 8th now g5 and now
Queen to d6 again offering the trade of
Queens
now comes Queen to h8 check and now rook
to e8 King to c7 of course doesn't work
is the same idea Queen comes to 8 and
black falls apart so after Queen to HH
check rook to e8 blocking and now Queen
to h4 threatening of course all sorts of
discoveries here we have Queen to g6
blocking this and now Queen to g4 Queen
to g4 threatening so many nasty tactics
one of them being of course Queen
captures on d7 that's not available at
the moment
but at some point it might be for
example first you would have to move the
rook for example to d2
because after you captured the rock only
17 captures then you want to capture
Bishop to f7 check when the Queen and
win the game first rook to e5 by Fabi
now this idea immediately isn't possible
due to the variation I just explained
our Bishop characters on f7 does not win
the game because you have Queen captures
on d3 see capture sin and
rook capture some g5 if black didn't
have time to capture this one pawn then
probably it would be winning but now
it's not
so after rook to e5 simply h4 guarding
that point so now this actually is a
threat King to e7 getting out of the way
but now not even not even playing a
Queen captures and e7 but a rope to d2
first getting the rock out of the way
now the Queen will no longer be able to
capture the rock on d3 so b5 here but
now comes and Bishop captures on f7
immediately attacking the Queen with a
double attack on the road can be seven
Queen to a5 blocking and now rook
captures and e7 King captures and here
it's a again a very not complicated
position but you could enter some
complications with Queen to d1 Cara can
probably saw that Queen to d1 is the
strongest move but he decided to play
Queen captures on f5 because this is
simply a force to win rook captures on
f5 and now g6 and the idea here is okay
Fabiano is still up the exchange but
this Bishop on f7 is a beautiful piece
it will constantly be guarding this e4
pawn and white doesn't mind the rook
will pick up the h4 pawn but after this
after this captures an b5 and all of the
pawns are being pushed on the Queen side
this is simply unstoppable
so King to e7 was played knock I'm seek
after some b5 rook to h5 see for now
rook captures on h4 now a4 is coming
rope to g4 a5 now King to d6 the King
has to go to the Queen side not to help
out with the defense a6 King to c7 and
King to b3 and after Sergei plate came
to be three this was move 48 it was in
this position that Fabiano Caruana
resigned the game so first loss in the
tournament for Fabiano Caruana and
Sergei kirkin now has 7 points out of 12
same as the tournament leader so far
Fabiano Caruana and I checked the main
criteria for the tiebreaks is there is
their encounter so because correction
beat Caruana if at the end of the
tournament that they have for example
both of them will have maybe nine points
then it will mean Kerrigan is the winner
because he he wins in the main criteria
here are tracking to be three the win is
completely obvious why a white was
simply waltz his king all the way up to
f6 and then push proof g7 and and
promote this pawn to a queen Black has
to play something
then simply king c3 rook can check King
d2 and after rook checks you don't have
to protect the b2 pawn you simply play
King to e3 now if rook captures pawn you
simply play g7 and the point is
unstoppable so you have to keep an eye
on the jeep on but now the King simply
goes up the board you attack the rook
rook goes back King a5 check King here
you simply have to protect the pawn now
comes King to f6 and now it's all over
you simply pull it upon and win the game
so yeah it was as at this point move 48
King b3 we can we can look at we can
look at the photo of Sergei another time
here he is the the monster of the
tournament who started off with with
minus 2 and then had had like the best
second half of the tournament like like
in ever and it's it's a similar story
than like what happened in the previous
candidates tournament Fabiana was all
also having a nice streak and then
nearing the end of the tournament Cara
can simply started winning games and
Fabiano got either scared of winning or
or I don't know maybe it's just that
Sergei Sergei has the best nerves out of
all of them and it's not that like I'm
too happy that Sergei is now in the lead
but you know I did say Sergei would win
the candidates before the candidates
even started so you know it does make me
a little bit happy so I'm just gonna say
it so yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it I don't have the final
standings for you as there are some
games still being played but I will show
you at least another game the demon
media of game is also very excellent so
I will show you that one and include the
final standings and the pairings for
around 13 so yeah that's the game once
again Thank You Nicki for the photos or
in this case one photo of this round
for those of you who maybe don't know
she's a photographer she's at the
candidates tournament everyday and
usually we do get some nice photos today
we got only one but you know we we can't
really complain as usual all of the
links to her social media are in the
description below
I feel joy just photography feel free to
follow follow her work and yeah as usual
you can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon with another game from the 2018
candidates tournament thank you all